هؤلاء تناولوا لحوم الكلاب
وعزل في خيام بمفردهم ثم خاضوا معارك
جسديه بعضهم ضد بعض في اجواء احتفاليه
راقصه
فليس سهلا هنا الحصول على لقبه رجل
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده وشعوب
مرحبا بكم في دولتي توغو في هذا البلد
هناك العديد من الخطوات التي على الفتيان
اتباعها لانظر اليهم كاشخاص بالغين ويتم
ذلك بحضور الجماهير ما تشاهدونه وهو
مهرجان ايفل في مدينه كلا شمال العاصمه
احتفال غنائي راقص يقام في شهر يوليو من
كل عام
ابطال المهرجانهم فتيانو قبيلتي كابيل
الذين تتراوحوا اعمارهم بين 15 و20 سنه
وهؤلاء لطخوا وجوههم واجسادهم بالطين او
بالوان البيضاء
طقس سنويا من العراق
ووفقا للتقاليد هنا تم عزل مئات الشباب في
خيام قبل اسبوع من بدايه المهرجان ليتناول
اللحوم الكلاب التي يعتبرونها رمزا للتحمل
والشجاعه وهي الصفات التي يحتاجها
المصارعون لهزيمه الاعداء خلال الحروب
وبعد ان يتناولوا ولمتهم يشكل المشركون
مجموعات مكونه من خمسه اشخاص لقتال بعضهم
بعضا استعدادا لتحمل مسؤوليات الحياه
ابو علاء
المصارعه التقليديه بين القبائل في توغو
نشات منذ مئات السنين
وتحولت عبر الزمن الى رياضه تهدف الى
اعداد الشباب القبائل جسديا وعقليا لمرحله
البلوغ
[موسيقى]
كوره
الامر في هذا المكان لا يقتصر على
الاحتفال والعراق
فهناك دورات توعويه صحيه يخضع لها الشباب
ليبدا حياتهم كرجال وهم بصحه جيده كل هذه
الطقوس الغريبه والفريده التي شهتموها
جعلت مهرجان ايفاله نقطه جذب مهمه للسياح
من داخل الدوله وخارجها
جميل باشا